HIGHER EDUCATION TO ORDER. AND-
BENHAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. MEDINA PRESIDENT CHOI HERE
ARAMBULA BLOOM GABRIEL IRWIN.
KILEY LEVINE. LOW SANTIAGO
PATTERSON WEBER. VERY GOOD SO
WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE ON
HIGHER EDUCATION FIRST BILL
HEARING. OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO
FOR LEGISLATIVE MEASURES WHETHER
YOU'RE HERE IN PERSON WATCHING
VIRTUALLY ARE ON THE PHONE LINE
I AM GRATEFUL THAT YOU HAVE
JOINED US. PLEASE NOTE THAT IS
SIMPLY MEMBER JIM PATTERSON HAS
BEEN APPOINTED TO REPLACE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS WHO SAT
VALADARES FOR TODAY'S HEARING
WELCOME ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PATTERSON GOOD TO HAVE YOU BACK
ON THE COMMITTEE. I WILL NOW GO
OVER SOME OF THE KEY ELEMENTS OF
THE STRUCTURE OF TODAY'S HEARING
. WHILE IT'S FUNNY LOOKING LIVE
WILL SOON BE BACK TO THE STATE
OF NORMALCY. WE'RE NOT THERE YET
. DUE TO THE ONGOING PANDEMIC WE
ARE PRACTICING PHYSICAL
DISTANCING IN THIS HEARING AND
THROUGHOUT THE CAPITOL BUILDING
. WE ARE ONLY ABLE TO HAVE A
LITTLE BIT LIMITED NUMBER OF
PEOPLE PHYSICALLY PRESENT TO
OBSERVE AND PARTICIPATE DURING
THIS HEARING. IF YOU ARE HERE IN
PERSON PLEASE NOTE THAT MASS ARE
STILL REQUIRED TO BE WORN AT ALL
TIMES MASS MUST COVER YOUR MOUTH
AND NOSE. WE HAVE A FEW
DIFFERENT OPTIONS FOR WITNESS
TESTIMONY TODAY IN PERSON AND
VIA THE PHONE LINES. IF A MEMBER
OF THE PUBLIC IN THE ROOM WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY ON A BILL PLEASE
RAISE YOUR HAND AND I WILL ASK
YOU TO APPROACH THE MICROPHONE
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME. I WOULD
ASK THAT YOU NOT. TOUCH THE
MICROPHONE. YOU CAN EXIT THE
HEARING ONCE YOU FINISH
TESTIFYING OR YOU CAN RETURN TO
YOUR SEAT. PLEASE BE SURE TO
OBSERVE PHYSICAL DISTANCING UPON
LEAVING THE CAPITAL INCLUDING
LIMITING THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE IN
THE ELEVATOR TO THE INDICATED
NUMBER. OF THE SIGNS POSTED BY
THE ELEVATOR DOORS. WE WILL BE
USING AN AT&T MODERATED
TELEPHONE SERVICE THROUGH WHICH
ANY MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC AND
EXPRESS THEIR- OPINIONS. THE
POSITION ON THE BILL THERE MAY
BE A SLIGHT DELAY SO AGAIN I ASK
THAT ALL INVOLVED. REMAIN
PATIENT. THE PUBLIC TOLL FREE
CALLING NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING.
IS ONE EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. SIX
NINE TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN.
AND THE ACCESS CODE IS. ONE
THREE ONE FIVE FOUR THREE SEVEN.
IT ALSO FIND THE NUMBER ON TE
ASSEMBLY HIGHER EDUCATION
COMMITTEE WEBSITE AS WELL AS ON
YOUR TV OR MONITOR SCREEN. IF
YOU'RE CALLING IN POLICE PLAN TO
DO SO THAT THE AUTHOR THE BILL
YOU'RE TESTIFYING ON IS
BEGINNING THEIR BILL
PRESENTATION. THE OPERATOR ON
THE LINE WILL GIVE YOU
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE PLACED
IN QUEUE BASED ON WHETHER YOU
SUPPORT OR OPPOSE THE BILL. IF
YOU'RE CALLING AND PLEASE
ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND NOISE
THIS INCLUDES MUTING YOUR LIVE
STREAM BROADCAST AND YOUR
SMARTPHONE DEVICES TO REDUCE THE
SOUND DISTORTION. PLEASE BE SURE
TO MUTE YOUR PHONE WHEN YOU'RE
NOT SPEAKING. IF YOU'RE HAVING
PROBLEMS WITH THE MODERATED
PHONE SERVICE PLEASE CALL THE
COMMITTEE OFFICE. AT NINE ONE
SIX THREE ONE NINE. THREE NINE
SIX OH AND COMMITTEE STAFF WILL
DO THEIR BEST TO ASSIST YOU.
PLEASE NOTE THAT WE ARE
ACCEPTING WRITTEN TESTIMONY TO
THE POSITION LETTER PORTAL ON
THE COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE.
ADDITIONALLY PLEASE NOTE THAT
THE GUIDELINE FOR BILLS HEARD IN
THIS COMMITTEE IS TO ALLOW
TESTIMONY FROM TO LEAD WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT. AND TO LEAD
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO SPEAK
FOR NO MORE THAN TWO MINUTES
EACH. STAKEHOLDER GROUPS AND
ENTITIES THAT ARE NEITHER IN
SUPPORT OR IN OPPOSITION WILL BE
ALLOWED TO GIVE TESTIMONY FOR NO
MORE THAN TWO MINUTES. WHEN I
CALL FOR TWEETERS. THE MEASURE
HAS MORE THAN TWO ENTITIES IN
THE TWEENER CATEGORY ONLY TWO
WILL BE ALLOWED TO SPEAK FOR TWO
MINUTES EACH. THANK YOU FOR
BEARING WITH US AS WE IMPLEMENT
METHODS TO CONTINUE TO SERVE THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA WHILE ALSO
BEING MINDFUL AND RESPECTFUL OF
THE PUBLIC HEALTH CONCERNS WE
ALL FACE. MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. MEMBERS OF YOU'D LIKE
TO RESPOND TO ROLL CALL ASK A
QUESTION OR PROVIDE A COMMENT.
YOU WILL NEED TO RAISE YOUR HAND
AND ACTIVATE YOUR VOLUME BUTTON.
ON THE DIETS MICROPHONES. FOR
AUTHORS OF THE BILL TODAY EACH
MEMBER PRESENTED TODAY WILL
PROVIDE AN OPENING AND CLOSING
STATEMENTS. AS I PREVIOUSLY
STATED YOUR LEAD WITNESS WILL
HAVE TWO MINUTES TO PROVIDE
TESTIMONY. WE HAVE THREE BILLS
ON THE AGENDA TODAY TO PREPAY TO
BE PRESENTED AND ONE ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. BILLS WILL BE
TAKEN UP AND FILE ORDER HOWEVER
I WILL PRESENT MY BILL LAST.
BILLS ON THE AGENDA OR A. B.
SIXTEEN TWENTY FIVE. FILE ITEM
ONE AB SIXTEEN SEVENTY ONE FILE
ITEM THREE AND THE BILL AND
CONSETT A. B. SIXTEEN THIRTY
THREE. FILE ITEM TO. SO AT THIS
TIME I WILL ASK FOR A MOTION.
AND A SECOND FOR THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. THE PROMOTION FOR THE
POINTS AND TENANTS. I HAVE A
MOTION BY DOCTOR CHOI A SECOND
BY. MR LOW. AND MADAM SECRETARY
IF YOU'D PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MEDINA AYE MEDINA AYE CHOI HI
CHOI I ARAMBULA. BLOOM BLOOM I
GABRIEL IRWIN. IRWIN I KILEY
LEVINE LEVINE I LO LO I SANTIAGO
PATTERSON. PATTERSON I WEBER
WEBER II. EIGHT EIGHT ZERO THAT
BILL IS THE THIRD THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IS OUT OF LEAVE IT OPEN
IF WE HAVE ANY ABSENT MEMBERS
NOW WILL GO TO- FILE ITEM ONE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PATTERSON IF YOU
. FILE ITEM THREE OKAY A. B.
SIXTEEN SEVENTY ONE. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PATTERSON WHEN YOU ARE
READY. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND- THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS. I WANT TO START FIRST
OF ALL BY- OF. LETTING OUT THE
COMMITTEE KNOWS HOW MUCH I
APPRECIATE THE WORK THAT THE
COMMITTEE HAS DONE. I AM GLAD TO
ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
THE BILL BEFORE YOU AB SIXTEEN
SEVENTY ONE WOULD PROHIBIT. ANY
CALIFORNIA COLLEGE WHO RECEIVES
STATE FUNDING FOR FROM REDUCING
SCHOLARSHIP FINANCIAL AID TO
STUDENTS WHO ARE CURRENT. OR
FORMER FOSTER YOUTH. THE
PRACTICE OF SCHOLARSHIP
DISPLACEMENT CURVES WHEN
STUDENTS RECEIVE A SCHOLARSHIP
FROM A PRIVATE SOURCE AND IS
REQUIRED TO REPORT THEIR
EARNINGS TO THE SCHOOL. THAT
SCHOOL CAN THEN REDUCE THE
NUMBER FINANCIAL AID DOLLARS.
THAT THE STUDENT RECEIVED
LEAVING THE STUDENT WITH FEWER
DOLLARS IN THEIR POCKET TO HELP
WITH THE EVERYDAY NECESSITIES.
THERE ARE ALREADY NUMEROUS-
CHALLENGES THAT CURRENT AND
FORMER FOSTER YOUTH BASE.
SPECIALLY WHEN IT COMES TO
PURSUING A COLLEGE DEGREE AND
SCHOLARSHIP DISPLACEMENT ONLY
FURTHER COMPLICATES THAT
DIFFICULT CIRCUMSTANCE. WHILE
MANY OF THE STUDENTS LACK FAMILY
SUPPORT. FINANCIAL RESOURCES AND
GUIDANCE THAT SO MANY OF THEIR
PEERS RECEIVE. IT IS ESSENTIAL
THAT THEY HAVE THE ABILITY TO
MAXIMIZE THEIR POTENTIAL THROUGH
THE SCHOLARSHIPS AND FINANCIAL
AID WITHOUT PENALTY. WITH THE
RISING COSTS OF EVERYTHING
AROUND US. IT'S RELATED TO
HIGHER EDUCATION AND DAILY
LIVING SOME PORTENT STEP
REMOVING A FINANCIAL BURDEN
PLACED ON INDIVIDUALS THAT CAN
LEAST BEAR THAT BURDEN. AB
SIXTEEN SEVENTY ONE WILL GIVE
CURRENT AND FORMER FOSTER YOUTH
AN OPPORTUNITY TO ACHIEVE A
COLLEGE DEGREE WITHOUT HAVING TO
WORRY ABOUT SO MUCH OF THE HEAVY
LOAD OF THE COST. AND WITH THAT
I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT. ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS- WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT IN THE HEARING ROOM.
AND EIGHTEEN T. MODERATOR ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
ON THE PHONE. BURKE ON IN THE
QUICK Q. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN TO
SHOW SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
BEEN THERE WHAT THIS TIME. I
HAVE NO COMMENT AT THIS TIME.
AND I DID NOT I DON'T KNOW THAT
I ASKED IF THERE WERE ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM. CASEY NINE ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION IN THE HEARING ROOM.
C. NINE EIGHT TEAM TNT MODERATOR
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. ON THE PHONE AND IN
THE QUEUE. GIVEN THE AMANDA SHOW
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
THERE WITH THIS TIME. BERMAN
ALLIANCE PREPOSITION AT THIS
TIME. ARE THERE ANY TWEETERS IN
THE HEARING ROOM. C. NINE
EIGHTEEN T. MODERATOR THERE ANY
TWEETERS ON THE PHONE OR IN THE
QUEUE. WELL LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU'RE A TRAINER PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR PHONE AT
THIS TIME. WE HAVE NOT AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU. MISTER MODERATOR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. WHO ARE
ASSUME ACCORDING TO THE BILL
THAT THAT THIS WOULD APPLY TO
ANY- HIGHER EDUCATION NONPROFIT
SCHOOL SIMPLE PUBLIC SCHOOLS OF
THIS INCLUDES. COMMUNITY
COLLEGES SO CSU AND UC SYSTEM SO
ALL OVERALL A YOU ARE NOT THE
LIMITING TO A CERTAIN CLASS OF-
HIGHER IDEALS A BILL WOULD
PROHIBIT ANY CALIFORNIA COLLEGE
WHO RECEIVED STATE FUNDING. FROM
REDUCING SCHOLARSHIP FINANCIAL
AID TO STUDENTS WHO ARE. CURRENT
OR FORMER FOSTER YOUTH. THAT IS
STATEMENT ENCOMPASSES. ALL THAT
APPLIES TO. I SHE ADDED THIS
MAKES THE MOST SENSE US SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU- MISTER
PATTERSON WOULD YOU LIKE- FIRST
LET ME GO TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. NO OKAY I MAKE A
MOTION FOR RIGHT AT. OUR MOTION
BY MISTER LOS SECOND BY DOCTOR
CHOI- MISTER PATTERSON WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT AND-
ALTHOUGH THERE WERE NONE IN
SUPPORT HERE. PUBLICLY THERE ARE
GROUPS IN THE STATE THAT SUPPORT
BUT I WOULD ALSO SUGGEST THAT
THERE ARE INDIVIDUALS HERE THAT
ARE HERE IN SPIRIT AND THESE ARE
THE FOSTER YOUTH THAT WOULD BE
BENEFITED BY THIS AND WE MAY
NEVER KNOW THEIR NAMES BUT IF
THIS PASSES. THEY WILL HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO GET AN EDUCATION
AT THE AND I'M GRATEFUL FOR THAT
AND I KNOW THAT. THEY WOULD SAY
THANK YOU AS WELL. WELL THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER PATTERSON
FOR BRINGING FORWARD THIS
IMPORTANT BILL AND THANK YOU FOR
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS
PROPOSED BY THE COMMITTEE AND I
WOULD JUST POINT OUT THAT I I'M
AWARE OF THE SIMILARITY BETWEEN
THIS BILL AND AB TWO EIGHT EIGHT
BUT I AM SUPPORTIVE OF THIS BILL
AS I AM OF AB TWO EIGHT EIGHT OF
MOVING FORWARD BECAUSE I AGREE
WITH YOU THAT NO SCHOLARSHIP-
DISPLACEMENT. SHOULD BE ALLOWED
I HAVE ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
AFTER YOUR QUESTION. THAT YEAH
DR CHOI YOU GO AHEAD WITH YOUR
QUESTION YEAH I WAS WONDERING
WHY THIS HAS TO BE LIMITED TO
ONLY FOSTER CURRENT FOSTER WALL
FORMER FOSTER CHILDREN SO WHAT
ABOUT THE MORE QUALIFIED
DEVELOPMENTAL- THE RECIPIENTS.
WOULDN'T IT BE BETTER TO MAKE IT
TO BECAUSE A TO ME IT DOESN'T
MAKE ANY SENSE SAYS JUST BECAUSE
I GET THE FEDERAL GRANT THAT.
ANY PRIVATE SCHOLARSHIPS I MADE
YOU KNOW ALL ON MY OWN EFFORT I
GET THE ADDITIONAL SCHOLARSHIPS
UP AND UP MY PREVIOUS-
GOVERNMENT CAPITAL GRANT THE
WOULD BE REDUCED- IT DOESN'T
MAKE ANY SENSE. CAN YOU EXPANDED
THAT TO INCLUDE THE ANY. ANY ANY
BAD WHEN THE RECIPIENT SECOND
BENEFIT THE SAME BENEFITS.
MISTER CHAIR OF THE PARTY YOU
YEAH. I JUST JUST TO SHARE THAT
WITH MY COMMENT WAS THAT THERE
IS A SIMILAR BILL MOVING FORWARD
THAT THAT- THAT ENCOMPASSES. ANY
STUDENT AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PATTERSON BILL FOCUSES AND-
UNDERSTANDABLY ON ON FOSTER YOU-
BUT THE OTHER BUILT ENCOMPASSES
ALL STUDENTS AND IT IS MY
UNDERSTANDING SO REMEMBER THAT
IF THE OTHER BILL YES WILL-
FIRST OF ALL IN THE PERFECT
WORLD. WOULD BE GREAT TO COVER
EVERYBODY AND THE BILL YOU
MENTIONED- I THINK TRIES TO DO
THAT. THIS BILL THAT FOCUSED ON
FOSTER AT KIDS. IF FOR SOME
REASON THE BILL YOU. JUST
OUTLINED STALLS FOR SOME REASON
MAYBE APPROPRIATIONS OR WHATEVER
YEAH WE CAN CONTINUE THIS BILL
IF IN FACT IT DOES GET THAT BILL
GETS TO THE FLOOR WE WILL
WITHDRAW THIS BILL BECAUSE IT
WILL COVER THOSE THOSE STUDENTS
AS WELL. YEAH OKAY THANK YOU
THANK YOU DR CHOI SO WE HAD A
MOTION BY MR LOW SECOND BY
DOCTOR CHOI- I'M SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE MOTION
IS DUE PASSED AS AMENDED TO THE
HUMAN SERVICES COMMITTEE MEDINA
HI MEDINA I CHOI HI CHOI I
ARAMBULA ARAMBULA AYE BLOOM.
BLOOM I GABRIEL IRWIN IRWIN I
KILEY KILEY I. LEVINE. LEVINE I
LOW LOW I SANTIAGO PATTERSON HI
PATTERSON I WEBER. WEBER AVE.
TEN ZERO THE BILL IS OUT DO WE
HAVE ANY ABSENT MEMBERS. YEP
OKAY SO LEAVE IT OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. CHOI. WHO WANTS TO MOVE. NEXT BAILOUT WILL BE AT AB
ITEM THREE. NO I'M SORRY A ITEM
NUMBER ONE AB- SIXTEEN TWENTY
FIVE- CHAIRPERSON- MEDINA S. B.
L. AND YOU ALREADY GO HEAD THEM
. MAKE A PRESENTATION. THANK YOU
BILL THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU MEMBERS FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF AB SIXTEEN
TWENTY FIVE WHICH IS AS SIMPLE
REASONABLE STEP THAT SEEKS TO
FURHER AMPLIFY THE VOICE OF
STUDENTS AND INCREASE THE PARITY
ON THE BOARD OF TRUSTEES OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY. THE
STUDENT MEMBERS OF THE BOARD OF
TRUSTEES EXERCISE A CRITICAL
ROLE. REPRESENTING MORE THAN
FOUR HUNDRED AND EIGHTY THOUSAND
STUDENTS AT THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY SYSTEM. THERE ARE
CURRENTLY TWO STUDENT MEMBERS ON
THE BOARD OF GOVERNORS. HOWEVER
THERE IS CURRENTLY A LACK OF
PARITY. BETWEEN FACULTY MEMBERS
ON THE BOARD AND STUDENT MEMBERS
ON THE BOARD. ON THE CSU BOARD
OF TRUSTEES OF FACULTY MEMBER IS
ALLOWED TO REMAIN IN OFFICE
AFTER THE TERM EXPIRES FOR ONE
ADDITIONAL YEAR OF THE GOVERNOR
IS NOT APPOINTED SUCCESSOR. THIS
IS NOT THE CASE FOR STUDENT
REPRESENTATIVES ON THE BOARD
THEREFORE THIS RISK A LACK OF
STUDENT REPRESENTATION AND INPUT
BETWEEN THE TIME OF THE STUDENT
REPRESENTATIVE IS FINISHED THIRD
TERM. AND THE GOVERNOR HAS
APPOINTED HIS SUCCESSOR. ASHLEY
NOW DURING THE COLD NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. THE STUDENT VOICE IS
NEEDED NOW MORE THAN EVER. WE
CANNOT AFFORD TO DIMINISH THEIR
INPUT BECAUSE OF THE LACK OF
PARITY IN STATE CODE. AB SIXTEEN
TWENTY FIVE RECTIFY IS THE LACK
OF PARITY. BY GRANTING THE
STUDENT TRUSTEE AN ADDITIONAL
SEMESTER TO CONTINUE SERVING IN
THE ROLE WHEREBY PROFESSORS CAN
CONTINUE TO SERVE IN THEIR
RESPECTIVE ROLE FOR SEMESTER.
UNTIL THE GOVERNOR FILLS THE
VACANCY. AB SIXTEEN TWENTY FIVE
ALLOWS THE STUDENT TRUSTEE WHOSE
TERM IS EXPIRING TO REMAIN IN
OFFICE. UNTIL JANUARY WIDE UNTIL
A SUCCESSOR IS APPOINTED BY THE
GOVERNOR WHICHEVER OCCURS FIRST
. AB SIXTEEN TWENTY FIVE IS A
SIMPLE YET IMPORTANT CLEAN UP
BILL TO FURTHER EMPOWER THE
VOICE OF STUDENTS ON THE CSU
BOARD OF TRUSTEES. THIS BILL IS
SPONSORED BY THE CALIFORNIA
STUDENT ASSOCIATION- TO TESTIFY
ON THE PHONE IN SUPPORT AND FOR
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS IS.
CHRISTIAN. HANNAH BRAG STEAD
FROM THE CALIFORNIA STUDENT
ASSOCIATION. OKAY THANK YOU- DO
YOU HAVE ANY. SUPPORT WITNESSES
YES WE HAVE A SUPPORT WITNESS ON
THE PHONE OKAY- SUPPORT WITNESS
A WIN IF YOU'RE ALREADY AHEAD
THE FIRST TWO MINUTES. YOU CHAIR
YOU GET BETTER AT MY NAME EVERY%
SINGLE TIME GOOD AFTERNOON
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
CHRIS I'M NOT SURE AND I SERVE
AS VICE PRESIDENT LEGISLATIVE
AFFAIRS THE CALIPHATE
INSTITUTION AND I'M A THIRD YEAR
STUDENT AT STANISLAUS STATE. SEE
IF THE STATE IS PROUD TO SPONSOR
OF THE BILL SIXTEEN TWENTY FIVE
AND WE ARE GRATEFUL TO CHAIRMAN
ENOUGH FOR INTRODUCING THIS
IMPORTANT PIECE OF LEGISLATION.
AB SIXTEEN TWENTY FIVE WOULD
ALLOW THE STUDENT TRUSTEE WHOSE
TERM IS EXPIRING TO REMAIN IN
OFFICE UNTIL JANUARY FIRST OR
UNTIL A SUCCESSOR IS APPOINTED
BY THE GOVERNOR WHICHEVER OCCURS
FIRST. VISIT CREE PARITY WITH
THE FACT THAT THE TEST TRUSTEE
WHO HAD THE GRACE PERIOD OF UP
TO ONE YEAR. UNTIL A SUCCESSOR
IS APPOINTED. THE THING IS
CURRENTLY WITH THE- WHAT THE
FINAL. ON EIGHTY FIVE FOURTEEN
INTO NINETEEN. WHICH GRANTED
BOTH TRUST VOTING. ON THE
CALIFORNIA STATE YOU. FOR OF
TRUSTEES. STUDENT TRUSTEE
THIRTEEN YEAR TERM THAT ARE SO
TO BEGIN ON JULY. AND EXPIRE ON
JUNE THIRTIETH TWO YEARS AFTER.
IN THE LAST FIVE SIX YEARS THE
STUDENT TRUSTEE POSITION HAS
BEEN APPOINTED IN AUGUST
CREATING A VACANCY FOR THE
SECOND STUDENT TRUSTEE AT THE
JULY BOARD OF TRUSTEES MEETING.
YOU TO BOTH CHIU INTERESTED NOW
HAVING THE RIGHT TO VOTE IT'S
CRITICAL THAT BOTH POSITIONS
REMAIN FILLED TO ENSURE THE
STUDENT VOICES HEARD AND ALWAYS
PART OF DECISION MAKING. IN THE
CASE OF A CLOSE VOTE OR
IMPORTANT POLICY DISCUSSION NOT
HAVING POSTED REPRESENTATION AND
VOICE IN THE SPACES. CAN
DRASTICALLY ALTER THE COURSE OF
ACTION AT THE KEY ISSUE TAKE.
STUDENT INPUT IS EXTREMELY
EXTREMELY CRUCIAL IN MAKING
DECISIONS WHICH IS WHY WE'RE SO
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. FOR THESE
REASONS. THEY ARE YOUR AYE VOTE
ON AB SIXTEEN TWENTY FIVE THANK. YOU OKAY ANY OTHER. SUPPORT
WITNESS. WHAT- A GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR AND MEMBERS CAN OF BAGHDAD
WITH THE CONCRETE IN THE NATION
AND THE ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS-
SHOULD THEY COME. OKAY ANY OUR
PUBLIC SUPPORT WITNESSES SO. IF
NOT THEN ANY OPPOSITION WITNESS. HOW ABOUT THE PUBLIC INPUT
THOUGH ON OPPOSITION ANYONE. IF
NOT THEY'LL RETURN TO- COMMITTEE
MEMBERS OF FOR YOUR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. YEAH. YEAH I WAS
ALREADY MOVED BY A SEMINAL
PATTERSON I BELIEVE WAS IT THE
WAS IT CORRECT MISTER LYLE AND
PROBLEM IS A- MR AND OF THE
PARIS AND PARIS SECOND OKAY BEEN
MOTION HAS BEEN MADE TO AND
QUESTIONS. I HAVE A THEN- I
WONDER- I IN WITH THIS MAKES A
LOT OF A SENSE OF WHY- SUCH A
VACANCY- WINDOWS THE TWO YEAR
TERM HAS EXPIRED THE EXISTED.
AND THE WITH THIS BILL REQUIRES
A SIX MYSELF- OF VACANCY IT
SHOULD NOT HAPPEN BY UP BY
ALLOWING EXISTENCE STERN BOARD
MEMBER TO CONTINUE. BUT- THE
SURPRISING YEAH I READ THAT THAT
THIS IS A- THE- GOVERNMENT
DOUBLE UP. THAT ESTABLISHED. IN
THE BOARD. SO IF THE SOLE. THAN
NON WHITE A GIRL- IN TWO OR
THREE- HE CAN. AND TIME HE KIND
SAID THIS SURVEY BECAUSE SHE HAS
HAPPENED REQUIRING THIS KIND UP-
NEW BILL YOU KNOW I WOULD IF I
COULD- MISTER CHAIR GO BACK TO
OUR STUDENT REPRESENTATIVE. TO
ANSWER THAT QUESTION- CHRISTIAN
COULD YOU ANSWER THAT THAT ARE
HOW MANY. TIMES IS THIS OCCURRED
IN THE LAST FEW YEARS. IF YES
STEP SO IN LAST FIVE OUT OF SIX
YEARS THE STUDENT TRUSTEE
POSITION HAS BEEN APPOINTED IN
AUGUST BUT A LOT OF BIG BE
CONSIDERING THAT YES THEY JUST
FINISHED UP. OUR STUDENTS
TRUSTEE INTERVIEWS AND WE'RE
CURRENTLY IN THE PROCESS
SUPPORTING THE NAME TO THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE- REALLY THE
DELAY AND THE LACK OF BEING IN
THE GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENT
OFFICE- OF FOR THE LAST FEW
YEARS RIGHT WE FINISH OUR
PROCESS RIGHT ABOUT THIS TIME
EVERY YEAR. AND WE DON'T HEAR
FROM TE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE UNTIL
AUGUST WHICH LEADS- WE THAT THAT
THAT THEY CAN BE IN JULY.
OBVIOUSLY THIS BILL. S. T. A.
DATE BY THE FACT THAT THAT HAS
HAPPENED BUT- I WONDER IF THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AS STAFF
MEMBERS SO IN PREPARATION OFF
THIS OF MAKING RECOMMENDATIONS
ARE RECEIVING APPLICATIONS SO-
THEY THEY COULD THE- AND PAPIR
WELL IN ADVANCE SO RATHER THAN-
CAUSING DISCOMFORT BAKER C. N.
DA REQUIRING DISK KIND OF A
SEPARATE BEYOND THE SYSTEM MIGHT
JUST A SUGGESTION THIS KIT
SIMPLER MATTER CAN BE TAKEN CARE
OF A BY CARE FOR SCHEDULING. OF
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AT ANY
RATE- THAT'S MY COMMENT AND- WE
HAVE A- MORE. AND A SECOND IF
FOR NO OTHER COMMENT THE- GO
AHEAD THE CLUB- I'M SO YEAH MAKE
A AFTER STATEMENT. I JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. OKAY
LOCAL HEAD DOWN TOWARDS THE ROLE
. THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
MEDINA HI MEDINA I CHOI AYE CHOI
AYE ARAMBULA ARAMBULA AYE BLOOM
BLOOM HI GABRIEL. GABRIEL I
IRWIN- WHEN I KILEY KILEY I.
LEVINE LEVINE I LOW. LOW I
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I PATTERSON
PATTERSON I WEBER WEBER HI.
TWELVE ZERO. BILL PASSES ARE
PROBLEMS ZERO TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE THANK
YOU. YEAH WITH ANY ADD ONS YEAH
I WILL DO ADD ON A PERSONAL DO
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA AYE GABRIEL GABRIEL I
KILEY KILEY I SANTIAGO. WELL
ZERO TO CONSENT CALENDAR IS OUT
. SENATE ITEMS THREE A. B.
SIXTEEN SEVENTY ONE GABRIEL
GABRIEL I SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I'D. ZERO SEVENTY ONE. THE RETURN.
UHHUH YEAH. YEAH MORE. WE GOT.
YEAH. YEAH THANK YOU.